Since HTML is structured,
we're going to want to break it up into words and punctuation and word-like elements,
and we use the special term token to mean all of those.
In general, a token can refer to a word, a string,
numbers, punctuation.
It's the smallest unit of the output of a lexical analysis.
Remember, that's what we're currently working on.
Mostly tokens do not refer to white space,
which is just a formal way of referring to the spaces between words.
We're going to be focusing on lexical analysis,
a process whereby we break down a string, like a sentence
or an utterance or a webpage, into a list of tokens.
One string might contain many tokens
in the same way that one sentence might contain many words.
Here I've written 6 HTML tokens,
given them names on the left and examples on the right.
Now, the naming of tokens is a bit arbitrary.
In general, though, tokens are given uppercase names
to help us tell them apart from other words or variables.
Here this left angle corresponds to an angle bracket
facing left presumably--not quite sure how to draw that.
The smaller end is to face.
Left angle slash is a < followed by a /, division sign.
The right angle bracket, > facing to the right.
Here's the angle. Here's the face.
The equal sign is just =.
A string is going to have double quotes around it,
and a word is anything else, welcome to my webpage, punctuation like that.
Now, it turns out that the naming of tokens is not quite an arbitrary matter.
You may think I'm as mad as a hatter.
No, that's a different story.
We're just going to go with these token names for now,
but if you were designing a system from the ground up,
you can rename them to be anything you like.